hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll and today's episode is going to
be one of the more ambitious
mind-bending episodes that we get here
on mindscape but not because we're doing
some esoteric physics or mathematics
subject we're thinking about human
beings today's guest is herb gintus who
originally became well known as an
economist but these days probably better
to classify him as a behavioral
scientist because really herb's whole
thing the thing he really wants to get
across is
there's something called how human
beings behave and we should study and
develop theoretical models for that
behavior in a rigorous quantitative
empirically based way and then whatever
we learn about how human beings behave
should inform economics but also
psychology sociology anthropology and so
forth these different disciplines might
care about different aspects of human
behavior but they should ultimately tell
compatible stories about human behavior
right to me this is just pushing all my
buttons because this is a very poetic
naturalist way of looking at human
beings there are different vocabularies
for describing them but they better be
at the end of the day consistent with
each other in some deep sense so how do
you do this well herb has some ideas
about how to do this
roughly speaking based on the idea that
we need to understand
the sense in which human beings are
rational there's this whole story about
rational choice theory which kind of
gets a bad name because we think we know
what the word rational means and it
doesn't mean that in the sense of
rational choice theory he suggests the
name beliefs and preferences as a
replacement for rational choice theory
but we're stuck with the name but the
idea is that people have beliefs and
preferences faced with different
situations they will act in certain ways
we can study those ways using the tools
of game theory to understand why they
would think that they have incentive for
behaving one way rather than another and
then you can use ideas from actual
empirical psychological studies as well
as biology and evolutionary psychology
to think about why people don't
maximize their one shot return in a game
they're going to play
rationality is not completely
individualistic in these situations it's
social rationality so her wants to unify
all of the human sciences you know like
i said very very ambitious point of view
i'm not enough of an expert to judge
whether he's right but much of what he
says is completely compelling to me and
he's also extremely entertaining and
provocative while saying it so i think
this is going to be a popular episode
buckle up hold tight let's go
[Music]
do herb gintis welcome to the mindscape
podcast it's great to be here
so i get the impression and maybe this
is unfair correct me if i'm wrong from
reading your stuff and listening to you
talk that
you have a certain sense of frustration
about the fact that
psychology and economics and sociology
and anthropology are all separate
disciplines rather than sort of one big
discipline of human behavior is that
exaggeration
i wouldn't say exactly that what what i
would say is like in the physical
sciences or the natural sciences
there are overlaps
in chemistry and physics or
biology and chemistry etc but when they
overlap they agree and if they don't
agree then they fight about it and
figure out what the truth is
but in the social sciences
they they overlap but they
they say totally different things
so for instance economists classically
would say you know people are motivated
by self-interest
and you have to give them the proper
incentives
and there's no notion of morality
but in sociology they don't even talk
about incentives they always talk about
norms
and
violation of norms and proper behavior
and improper behavior etc etc well they
can't both be right and in fact they're
both wrong
and now
there's some other fields like for
instance economics and biology
both use what's called the rational
actor model
biology you maximize fitness
in economics you maximize something
called utility
but they're both rational actor models
other fields like in psychology you can
read 10 textbooks and they'll all say
rational actor model stupid it's not
correct we don't use it at all
so what's going on here it's not science
and uh you know i attribute it to the
fact that you have these
developed the early 20th century these
feudal fiefdoms where if you're an
economist
you publish in certain journals and you
talk to other economists and
you don't care what sociologists say
nobody cares because they they don't
hire you they don't fire you they don't
publish you yeah they don't go to
conferences with you
and so they they develop in strange
directions but if you care about the
truth
it's a scandal it's terrible it can't be
right
to just forget about these
you know um
conflicts between the way they model
human behavior
in one field or another and also in in
biology and biology
there's a tendency towards saying that
everything is uh inclusive fitness
that is what you do is what an
individual does is he helps himself and
his nearby relatives that's not true for
humans
it's not true for many social species
they have very complex relationships
that go way beyond
kinship so anyway that's what that's
what the issue is
and i mean not i'm very much on your
side here i tend to agree uh but so to
be play the devil's advocate is it
conceivable that
for the purposes of economic behavior
people act one way and four purposes of
social behavior they act another way and
actually these are compatible secretly
uh no i mean of course that's possible
but it isn't true
people do not behave in the economy as
though they are self-interested right
now when you have very
complete markets
you get
almost self-interested behavior but when
you get interactions among people
face-to-face interactions or other
social interactions even in the economy
people do not behave self-interestedly
people in a firm that work together
have a culture
and it could be a very
positive culture that promotes
cooperation and the openness or a very
backbiting culture which which uh
inhibits cooperation and these are
economic behaviors
uh very important ones having to do with
the organization of the labor
uh and
similarly consumers care a lot more than
just about
the uh
physical attributes of what goes into
their consumption they care about values
right
they care about who you know for
instance if you buy nike shoes you want
to know that your nike shoes weren't
made by slave labor
well that's not uh self-interested
etc so and similarly sociologists just
forget about
the incentive side of uh
of behaviors and they partially
characterize some things but not
completely
uh so
my argument is when you put them
together
um you you get much more complete
behavior much more explainable behavior
i mean it seems so obviously true what
you're saying at least the part that you
know they should sit down and hash
things out that it's a little bit
shocking that they don't or that they
haven't i mean i know the the siloing of
academia etc um i feel it myself but
still
one wants to say is it really that bad
but maybe it just is
oh yeah oh absolutely it's totally that
bad look at look at sociology and
anthropology what do they do they both
study human organization
they have totally different reading
lists they don't even overlap
margaret mead is not studied by
sociologists and talented parsons is not
studied by anthropologists how is it
possible you're going to have a theory
or a model of human
um social organization
if you divide the world up into two
places which are
which have totally different theories
yeah i
can't i can't argue with you can i say i
mean that's the way it is
now i'll tell you this
when i started out and uh
working on these issues
economists would say well we have to
assume
that people are self-interested because
otherwise you could just put anything
you want into their utility function and
it doesn't really explain anything
uh
and the answer to that and that's a very
good objection if all you're doing you
say oh okay this guy
um when he goes to the dump he always
travels around
by his brother's house it's way out of
the way but he likes to go by his
brother's house so i put that into his
utility function well that's a big help
i mean all you're doing is is epic
cycles on behavior
the problem there the answer to that is
we now have a whole discipline called
behavioral game theory
in which we take subjects in the
laboratory and see how in fact
they behave
and infer what they value from uh their
behavior and that is very advanced now
yeah it's
they've been nobel prizes for it uh
danny kahneman daniel conomon the
psychologist
richard saylor
so we go into this to the lab and then
we can figure out what people value
and the the the objection to the
standard theory goes away
well yeah i mean and i want to get to
the specifics of how we do that but i
mean everything you're saying
pokes at another thing that i've heard a
criticism of economics which is that
it's not nearly as empirical
as it should be you know we have a
theory we like the theory and rather
than testing the theory against data or
experiments we just elaborate the theory
more and more that's a cartoon but is it
is there some validity to that kind of
criticism well let me divide it into two
parts first of all when you learn
economic theory
there are no facts
i had an amusing thing happen to me many
years ago about but when i started
working on this one summer i was
studying this big thick
thousand page book one of gr for
introductory graduate economics students
on economics
everybody reads it around the world
and i was also reading a book on quantum
mechanics
and in the quantum mechanics book i
learned
black body radiation problem
compton scattering
um
lamb effect all sorts of empirical
effects that gave rise to
um the standard model
in the economics book there wasn't a
single empirical fact not one
thousand pages no facts
and
the fact is what the economists are
trying to do
is derive human behavior from the
concept of rationality yeah what is it
rational to do and you can't do that
because there's huge numbers of
variables involved
and rationality does does is important
but it doesn't determine which one you
choose
so um
i would say that's right and theorists
really do not like experimentalists in
economics
uh it's it's quite different from
physics where you know there's a deep
respect for the incredible you know
versatility and and depth of knowledge
of the experimenters
but uh not in economics we pretend to
have a rivalry between theory and
experiment but in fact we both know that
uh we need each other uh desperately and
hope that each other are doing good
things but but oh my gosh yes yeah
exactly
it's not like that in economics at all
no but now of course there is a side of
there
there is a branch of economics applied
economics like applied macro economics
and this and that and they use data all
the time
all the time but they usually don't use
much of theory they put it in the
computer and let the uh
regression coefficients tell you what's
going to happen
i i would argue that's a different
mistake but yes that's right so yeah but
let's get back to this this issue of
game theory and rational behavior i mean
in some sense i do get the impression
that uh you do
you take the rational actor model
seriously even if you don't think it's
the complete story so what is the sense
in which we can think about people in
some senses acting rational in what
sense can you yeah
yeah okay the
the overall
my overall statement about this is very
simple there are two of the behavioral
sciences that have core theories meaning
all over the world people learn the same
thing
and that that's economics and biology
and these are the two disciplines that
use the rational actor
psychology
is all over the place there's always
these new theories and people hate the
old theories and there's no
cumulative development of theory
and similarly in anthropology there are
ways of
of popularity of different views but
there's no core theory
so i argue that the rational actor model
is exactly what you need in order to
have a core theory of out of animal or
human behavior and the the disciplines
that ignore that
um just don't get very far they they end
up being voguish
and
scattered all over the place
and the reason this happened was
historical namely that the rational
actor model for huge you have to know
some math
you can't just do statistics you really
have to be able to model mathematically
the way you do in physical chemistry or
or biology
so uh they try to avoid that and the
people in it all agree that we don't
want to use it the real reason i think
is it's it's just hard to do it's really
hard to use the rational actor model in
biology and economics
but it's a very important uh
part of the discipline
i was by the way there's a wonderful
statement i once heard
a psychologist said he was giving a talk
and he said people aren't rational i'm
sorry people aren't logical they're
psychological
i thought
well yeah i mean the the joke i heard
was that if you don't like math you go
into sociology and if you don't like
emotions you go into economics so
exactly it could be something that's
clear too
and you you learn as a graduate student
to make fun of the other discipline
[Laughter]
you know you really learn that you learn
oh
and if it would be like if you were
doing natural science and so it said oh
in chemistry you know we don't believe
in this uh we don't believe in this uh
uh relativity theory we have
christomantism right it's a real nice
alternative physicists are all crazy
it's something like that but it goes on
all the time
in this behavioral sciences
your home is a place that should bring
you as much joy as possible and you can
show off what makes you you
joy bird's selection of customizable
furniture and modern home decor lets you
bring your unique style into your space
and with summer winding down joybird has
all the modern outdoor furniture and
accessories you need to make the most of
your patio hangs and joybird is
committed to creating quality furniture
and a more sustainable future each piece
is made with incredible care using
responsibly sourced materials free of
harmful chemicals through partnerships
with groups like one tree planted joy
bird is helping conserve and restore
earth's most precious natural resources
quality craftsmanship stain and scratch
resistant fabrics and limited lifetime
warranty joy bird furniture can handle
anything your family throws at it
literally and joybird stands by its
quality and craftsmanship if it's not
everything you hoped for just send it
back
so create a space that brings you joy
with joy bird visit joybird.com
mindscape and get 30 percent off your
purchase that's thirty percent off at
joybird.com
mindscape
okay but the rational actor model then
um you're suggesting is a
uh
a root to a core theory in economics and
biology and should it be even broader
than that is it the good starting point
for these other ways of thinking about
human beings
yes i mean
there have been if you look at the
literature on the irrational actor model
there have been dozens of criticisms of
it
outside of economics and biology
and they're all wrong
it's hard to believe very intelligent
people say really silly things about it
mostly because they don't understand it
but
the rational actor model does have one
i think serious defect
okay and here it is
um the rational actor model is room's
individual minds have individual what
they call subjective priors that is
individual ideas
about how the world works yeah and the
probabilities you attach to different
behaviors
but i think in the real world people
have what we call
um
entangled minds
that is your what you believe and what
you think is a function not of you
yourself but of your
network of entangled brains around you
the people you agree with people in your
family the people in your social group
and this and that
so you people become very very adamant
about what's true and what's false
and they believe it only because
everybody else they know believes it if
you go to a different place they believe
completely different things and this is
an important part of
rational behavior that people form
beliefs which they validate not against
empirical evidence all the time but
simply they validated against the
beliefs of everybody else
and this is a weakness of the theory i
think for at least for humans i don't
think it really is that important for
any other species
but how do we um i just want to hear in
your words how we dismiss
the most naive objections to the
rational actor model namely that people
do stupid irrational things all the time
okay
first of all that you have
this is a very important point it's a
good point bringing up
there's a lot of mean the word rational
means all sorts of different things but
here's what it there's two meanings that
you can give it in economics or in
biology or where the rational outcome is
one is called instrumental rationality
that means you have a goal
and rationale being rational means
you're choosing the means to get to that
goal most efficiently the fastest the
cheapest etc that's called instrumental
rationality yeah
so
but there's another called formal
rationality an individual is formally
rational
if
his preferences are transitive what that
means is if you prefer a to b and b to c
you prefer a to c
that's four that's all there is to it
there's a little bit more to get
bayesianism into it but very little more
it's basically you prefer a to b for b
to c
then you prefer a to c
and let me give you an example
you see a guy fall down in the subway he
fainted
what do you do
well instrumental rationality help the
guy get up
but that's not what happens what happens
is you say oh jesus i'm late for work
let somebody else help him up i don't
want to hurt my shoes
i want to help him up but i want to get
as far away as possible as soon as the
guy gets up in other words you have
multiple goals you don't have single
goals and instrumental rationality is
irrelevant then what you need is a
formal rationality
and that's what's
what i think we use when we say this is
how people behave we don't say they're
trying to achieve some goal we say that
they have
preferences which are transitive so that
we can model them using
a mathematical uh
decision theory right and so it can seem
to us from the outside that they are in
fact
being dumb or being irrational but at
the moment they are just doing what
their preferences say they should do and
that's all we know that's right so so
for instance you know if you smoke
cigarettes that's pretty stupid thing to
do these days
but it's not irrational it's it's
people do things all the time to hurt
themselves we know that i do
i don't like it i wish i didn't
but we all do that and we also make we
also make what's called performance
errors that is you try to do x but you
don't you don't do it right you your
logic is a little bit it's a complicated
thing to do so there are errors all over
the player uh when someone behaves crazy
you're not sure why is it because they
really have some underlying rational
transitive behavior or are they just
momentarily out of their minds who knows
the point is that no one's ever
developed anything alternative to uh the
rational actor model that you can use
systematically to explain behavior but
that word rational is a little bit
overloaded and that gets us into trouble
i know i've i tried to change it i i
started saying
i called it what did i call it
the beliefs and preferences model
i like that it's not going to go on but
i guess it's not an acronym for it
but people
it didn't hold so i i say rational and
say what i mean by rational formal
rationality and by the way it doesn't
mean you're self-interested either
that's the other thing people think if
you
it's
rational means you only care about
yourself
well that's of course ridiculous if the
only people who only care about
themselves are sociopaths
seriously i mean we all care about you
know a wide variety of things besides
ourselves
except for 10 of the population that are
real sociopaths and as a minor
technicality here uh my impression is
that if you have a consistent set
of preferences that can always be
modeled as you're trying to maximize
some utility function even if that's not
actually what you're doing it's just
sort of a formal equivalence right
right that's that that's you know the
fundamental theorem of rational actor
model they talk about utility and
maximizing something
but it's all really it's that's not
what's really going on it's what's
really going on is
for mathematical
purposes it's really nice to have a
function you can maximize
you bring in the calculus and
differential equations and all that
stuff very happy but what people are
really doing is just having preferences
which are transitive
and then you can build the um utility
function out of that
yeah and and once you do that that's
when game theory becomes a useful tool i
mean maybe you should talk a little bit
about
game theory i mean probably people know
what the words mean but uh
do
does game theory really give us a useful
model for how people behave i mean maybe
you're saying that it does in the sense
of this beliefs and preferences you know
i wrote four books one game series it's
a leading question yeah
no i think it's the
along with the rational actor model it's
one of the central tools for behavioral
uh behavioral science
um
games used to be
well it started out with von neumann and
morgan stern at
princeton
uh trying to model um you know war games
and poker but it's it's
the major development that happened in
game theory was really in biology
when um
maynard smith john maynard smith and
price
developed a game theory
game theoretic model to explain fights
among butterflies
for uh mating space
and it developed into a whole theory of
what's called evolutionary game theory
um which has i think the basis for the
understanding the dynamics of
behavioral um behavior of animals and
humans so it's used all the time in
economics and biology
it's used all the time actually in
political science
um
although there i hope we get time i'll
tell you there's some really funny
things going on
applying it to
things like voting behavior
um
but yeah game theory is very simple
it's decision theory
with more than one
rescission maker right
in a situation where there are only
certain things that the two the various
decision makers know about what the
others are doing it's like when you play
bridge you know i have my hand you have
your hand and i can signal a bit where
mine is and you can sing a little bit
with your is
but basically we we don't know what the
other one's doing all we know is we're
all trying to win the game
so in the game theory you have
players it could be two three four five
or ten thousand
and each player has a strategy set to
choose from
and when each player chooses a
particular strategy
there's a particular payoff to the whole
to each person in the group
and that's game theory
and um you know i've argued and a lot of
people argue that it's really the basic
language
that can be used across all behavioral
disciplines whether you're talking about
dung beetles on cow patties or you talk
about humans voting in uh elections etc
etc
it's the same thing it's a game it's got
players got strategies players make
choices
and the payoffs depend on the
various choices the players have made
yeah and that's game theory and i think
the one
concept within game theory that will be
helpful for the best of conversation is
the equilibrium idea i mean the famously
there's the nash equilibrium so i'll let
you say what that is because i'm sure
you understand it better than i do okay
john nash was this incredible and
incredibly bright mathematician
at princeton
uh he had mental problems which really
destroyed him for most of his life
um but he invented as a young very young
man the concept of nash equilibrium
which is the equilibrium of a game
occurs where no player has an incentive
to change his behavior so everybody one
everybody then play plays it but they
they're doing the best they can
everybody's doing the best he can do and
that's called an equilibrium because
nobody has an incentive to change
now
when you learn game theory
you learn
they tell you something like this almost
always because i've taught graduate
students and i know what they have
learned
they say
rational players choose nash equilibria
well that's just false
i'm not going to go through it in detail
but it is just that's absurd now there
are articles in the uh literature that
show you clearly
the prerequisites for saying
that players choose nash equilibrium and
they're extremely implausible
um
so then you say well why do you say
game theory's so interesting oh bother
you if you want me to give you an
example i will
have you ever heard of um
uh
uh
flipping coins i have i flip a coin and
you flip a coin we have and and
uh i'm sorry not for bitcoin flipping
fingers
you put out one or two fingers i put out
one oh yeah good
right if we both put out the same number
of fingers you win if we put out
different numbers of fingers i win
how do you play the game well the notch
equilibrium is you play 50 50. half the
time you put out one half the time you
put out two that's nash equilibrium
problem
if you are playing 50 50
it doesn't matter what i do i can play
all heads
or all tales
because it doesn't matter what i do
moreover you know that it doesn't matter
what i do so there's no reason for you
to do 50 50 either
you get it yes when i tell my students
they complain to the dean
no i'm kidding
they don't complain
but
here's the point
now here's the very important point i
wrote a whole book on this called game
theory evolving
in an evolutionary game
where people
play the game over and over
and the people who do well
get to reproduce more like in a
darwinian evolutionary sense
then the only equilibria of that
dynamical system
is a nash equilibrium of the underlying
game okay and that justifies
using uh game theory
for uh in situations where you've had
social evolution right because social
evolution
will favor people who choose
strategies which in the long run lead to
um a nash equilibrium in the system and
okay so for instance if you have a whole
bunch of people playing
uh
one finger two fingers the throwing
fingers
they will evolve towards 50 50. yeah in
any one
instance it doesn't matter what they do
but the people who play 50 50 in the
long run do better
so they evolve
and what some of the subtleties here are
because
in various games various different kinds
of payoffs you could get for making
choices there's more than one nash
equilibrium and you could get stuck
because the definition of lash
equilibrium is that no one can
unilaterally
improve their life by changing but if
you cooperate if you're not competing
then in principle everybody could get a
higher payoff yeah
well now anyway you said there's two
different things first of all there are
multiple there can be multiple
equilibria
now
some
nash equilibria will never be attained
in an evolutionary sense
they're just
evolutionarily irrelevant
other times there's multiple equilibria
and they have bases of attraction and if
you get into one basin of attraction you
go to one equilibrium you get into a
different one you go to another one so
it's basic dynamical systems theory how
that might work out the second thing is
it
i don't know there's not many situations
where
universal cooperation
is a nash equilibrium
unless there are no earth
if people make no errors
then you can sometimes support
um you can't support a complete
cooperation equilibrium in a game just
by making a new game and saying look
we'll all cooperate if it ever one
person does not cooperate then we never
cooperate again forever
well it's called a trigger strategy
uh and that's fine until there's a you
know someone gets sick and they don't
come to work one day they say okay we
can't cooperate anymore he didn't
contribute right so if they're errs then
you have
big complications and the models become
much more sophisticated
and uh
uh cooperation is almost never
universal
okay fair enough so but then there is
this new idea that i found in in your
book in one of your books which is that
of a kantian equilibrium
after emanuel content the categorical
imperative oh yeah so uh explain that to
us i i don't think it's original with
you but um it certainly changed my well
i don't know in fact
the idea of a kantian equilibrium is as
old as kant i mean
the
the categorical imperative really
um is a game theoretic concept which
saying
which says
i will choose a strategy
which if everybody chose we would all do
really well we're gonna do best um and
if everybody else chooses that strategy
then uh we have a continent equilibrium
now the problem with that is that may be
true but
even if
it still could be that i do better if i
if i violate
the cooperation
so for instance i go to sleep rather
than go hunting with the other guys
so a continent equilibrium is a moral
equilibrium usually it says
to behave morally i should do x y or z
and i was always very um
suspicious of that idea but i decided a
few years ago that kant was you know
he's right on target in understanding
human morality
for instance let me give you an example
this is something which is
it's so pervasive
that it's it's it's stunningly
mind-blowing if you're rational
according to the rational actor model
you don't vote
you'll never vote
why
well it doesn't you say well so if you
know if you care about other social
issues you'll vote
the only reason you might not vote is
because you're self-interested no
it doesn't matter what you care about
no vote in a large election an election
more than 40 000 voters
no vote has ever been determined by one
person
okay so no individual has ever
determined the outcome of one of these
elections
so when you go to vote
you know the fact is you're not going to
change
what happens no matter what you do
so why vote
moreover why even read the newspaper
about politics it's a waste of time
you can't change the outcome of an
election
but people vote
and they care about the election
and in fact
you know i've done this
i've done this stand in line while you
vote this is before they could get a
pandemic oh yeah stand in line and tell
you the person why are you here they say
what do you mean why i'm here because
i'm here because i want the john smith
to win
and i say
well yeah but you know do you think your
vote's going to change the outcome oh no
of course not
well then why vote
they say listen to a good answer
if that if everybody thought that way
right
we can't have a democracy it's the
kantian move
the kantian move exactly it's it's not
just
so highfalutin philosopher
it's
deep in our souls that this notion that
we should behave in ways
which if everybody behaved we'd all be
better off
and this is a
the deepest moral principle of human
life
i believe
and people obey they obey it so much
that they don't even know they're
obeying it if you ask someone why are
you standing in line they make it sound
like they're going to change the
election right
right so so so all i'm saying is that we
have these deep
people make moral choices which go way
beyond the rational actor model towards
what i call
um a social rationality
which
which which no one's really explored
that much except the part that i'm
talking about
um voting in elections but the whole
idea that people are self-interested if
they vote in an election is incompat
just think inconsistent you may vote for
your social group
if you're a union member you may say
okay i vote the union
that doesn't make me selfish
if i was selfish i wouldn't vote at all
anyway you get the idea i do and you
mentioned something very provocative
along the way there which is that people
do it and you just gave a sort of uh
justification for why they do it but the
people themselves aren't necessarily
good at giving that justification i mean
i've heard are not excuse me are not
necessarily good at giving the correct
reason why they are doing this thing oh
no they're doing
you know
analysts online or in newspapers when
they say go out and vote they don't
really give you the right reason to do
it right
well they're
they can't it's it's there's no right
reason
i mean
there's an unarticulated notion of
social rationality but it's so
sophisticated
that you can't give it as a reason i
mean we're talking about it now but i
swear to god it took me five years
before i understood it
you know it's it's a i understood the
idea that you people have selfish
preferences and altruistic preferences
but it didn't occur to me for years that
people can have altruistic preferences
and still if they're irrational they
won't vote
okay it's very difficult and by the way
some audiences never i talked about this
a lot
in in some audiences they simply do not
understand what you mean
when you say you can't affect the
outcome of election
they immediately go to say well if
everybody thought that
uh
you know we couldn't run a democracy
yeah which is true
but but so anyway these are the deep
issues that come out when you try to
deal with the nature of human morality
it's
deeply
intertwined with the notion of
rationality and choice
the internet is a great place to find
little nuggets of this or that but
sometimes you want something more
substantial a little bit more sustained
introduction to some area of knowledge
that's why i love wandriam that's
r w-o-n-d-r-i um it's the streaming
service that our brains can't get enough
of there's so much to explore i love it
if you're familiar with the great
courses plus then you already know one
dream it's the same great service now
bigger and better with even more hours
of video and audio content fascinating
documentaries helpful how to's and
answers to every question you've ever
had for example as a change of pace i've
been enjoying the real history of
pirates which is such a fun watch if
you've ever seen movies about pirates or
been interested in pirate legends you'll
love learning the truth about pirates i
know you'll love wondrium so i put
together a special offer for minescape
listeners a free month trial of
unlimited access just go to the special
url wondrium.com
mindscape that's w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m.com
mindscape think of how much you'll learn
in just one month go to onedream.com
mindscape
is it somehow is it too cheap to
attribute this to the fact that we
talk and reason as consequentialists but
we act more deontologically in some
sense more more rules based well i don't
i i
some people i'm sure that's true of a
lot of people don't talk
consequentialist at all
i mean about politics no way
the biggest thing about politics most
people are not consequentialists they
think they want to
they want to vote for what's right what
they want to happen what's right
and uh
that
you know so
uh
that could have any kind of consequences
i think people are fundamentally in many
ways not consequentialist
they they don't think in terms of uh
uh what the consequences are they think
in terms of what's right and what's
wrong
well yeah i mean my own my own thinking
about morality is going undergoing a
very gradual shift way back in the days
when i was a kid i was absolutely a
utilitarian a consequentialist and just
the more i think about it the more just
doesn't work for a whole bunch of
reasons but i'm not exactly sure
what i am i mean as a as a meta-ethicist
i'm a moral constructivist i think that
there's no objective morality out there
that we make it up but i'm not sure what
the best thing to make up is and my
understanding of what you're talking
about it's not even necessarily a way of
saying here's what the best morality is
but just saying here's how people
actually
behave right i mean you're trying to be
more descriptive than prescriptive here
oh yeah well that's the difference
between um
a philosophical approach to morality
yeah in which people are searching for
the what is truly moral and what is not
and a behavioral approach which is just
to say how do people behave
it's it's really interesting that people
actually take morality seriously
i mean and it's not at all what the
philosophers uh expect by the way this
is an interesting thing now of course
the philosophers are doing more
behavioral game theory
and they understand what's wrong
perhaps i should give you an example of
a behavioral game
would you like that yes please
okay
maybe you'll do more than one but the
simplest one is called the dictator game
okay you can play it in the laboratory
although i could if i have time i could
tell you how it's played out in the
field
as well as a laboratory the dictator
game they're two players a and b
and they they don't they never see each
other they're in different rooms they
never get together and the experimenter
comes in
and tells both of them i'm giving b ten
dollars
b can offer any thing he wants to you
from one to ten if you accept the offer
we split the money the way
he he wanted
and if um
if you reject the offer you both get
nothing right i take the ten dollars but
i remember this one yeah
okay so
what does the and one of them is called
the proposer he's the one that's going
to offer the other one that's a
and b is the responder he's going to say
yes or no
now if both players are self-interested
player a will offer player b a dollar
and player b will accept it
why because otherwise he loses a dollar
why do that
yeah and player a says well player b is
self-interested so if i offer him a
dollar he'll take it and i get nine
[Music]
when you play this game that has never
happened
and we've played it in you know we've
played it
in societies not only you know in boston
massachusetts and in the
palo alto california we've played it in
the peruvian jungles
in the uh mongolian highlands
uh in african
jungles et cetera et cetera nobody ever
plays it that way the most common offer
is is half
i'll give you five dollars fair and if
you offer three dollars or less in most
societies
people will reject it not a hundred
percent but enough so you shouldn't do
it
you should offer five
now if you ask a philosopher what is
going on okay what's really going on
here why did someone reject three
dollars
and the answer is because he's pissed
off at the unfairness of the proposal
and he he gets more pleasure
or satisfaction out of
depriving the proposer of seven dollars
than he does about getting three dollars
and the less the proposer offers
the wider the gap is if he offered one
well i lose one but he loses nine yeah
so it's retaliation it's revenge
it's uh
yes that's what it is there's another
word for it um retribution okay what's
the difference it's revenge and
retaliation
um if you asked for i've asked
philosophers like the conferences
they don't know what's going on they say
they don't know what's going to happen
they go all over the place
um what about economy okay so that
that's an example of how humans are not
self-interested
in particular they like to hurt people
who hurt them what do economists say
about this game what is their prediction
uh it was the by the way the economists
would say one dollar at least the
traditional ones but everybody knows now
that this has been done
hundreds of times
so everybody knows that there's a
concept of fairness
um and uh that's what's going on
um there's another game
i'll i'll do this one it's called the
it's an honesty game
there are two players again a and b
and they can't see each other
they can only communicate as follows
a is given
two piles
two boxes with with uh money in it
and a can look in the boxes and see how
much money is in each box
and then a can say to b
either
uh b
please choose
if if you want the most money choose box
one
or if you want the most money choose box
two
and then b can either choose box one or
box two
now if if people are um if people are
honest
then player a will say
choose the box that has the most money
in it and b will say well we're all on
it so i'll lose it
but why should a be honest it's costless
for him to say yeah uh choose box b good
choose box two
and then player two
player b rather
should say why why should i think he's
truthful
he's going to lie but i don't know he's
going to lie because he knows i might
think he might go to lie
like professor you know moriarty and
sherlock holmes you know
you can't tell what's right
what's the right statement so it's a
completely indeterminate game but when
you actually play this game
almost always player a tells the truth
as long as the splitting of the money is
not too uneven
uh player a will tell the truth and
player b
will
assume that player a is telling the
truth and so player a for telling the
truth loses money and player and and
knows he's gone expects to lose money um
there's complications on it but as you
see people don't like to be dishonest
yeah now i should say when you play this
game
if the stakes are not it's not the
height of the stakes it's not how much
the stakes are it's how uneven it is
if it's very uneven then player one gets
pissed off and says well i'm gonna lie
and uh you
you get the cooperation falling apart so
we play these kind of games all the time
uh and they show the extent to which
people are self-interested versus uh
altruistic or that to the extent to
which they believe honesty is important
etc well and surely a lot of this is
because
human beings in the real world interact
many many many times with many people
and develop senses of fairness and
expectations and even when you put them
in these isolated uh psychological tests
they're still going to bring those
external uh ways of thinking to bear
right that's exact that's exactly right
i mean we did the first
we did uh i had a large project it was
funded by the macarthur foundation some
years ago
and we have
16 anthropologists go to their countries
that they work in around the world
and play
things like the dictator game and the
ultimate game and the honesty game etc
and
when the results came back i and i was
putting them together
the result was that people take this
they take their values from their
society whatever they are
and they they take them into the
laboratory even in conditions of
complete anonymity no one will ever find
out and they behave in the same ways as
as they do in their societies very
egalitarian societies people play
the um ultimatum game which i haven't
really just yes i have that's the
ultimate is what i described not the
dictator game okay excuse me i described
the ultimatum game not the dictator game
uh from the very beginning okay
um
and it was a shocker to me um it
reminded me of the old sociologists uh
the brilliant sociologists talk at
parsons is that the values really matter
values do really matter
um
really i mean there's societies where
for instance people do cooperative
hunting like for instance the lamellara
in the pacific um who hunt whales they
hunt together in a big boat
and they split it up in a very
egalitarian way
when they play the game they do what's
called hyper fare offers the player a
when he gets ten dollars he offers the
other guy eight dollars
and if he offers him too much the other
guy rejects it
[Laughter]
can you believe that why no here's why
you ask him why did you reject seven
dollars
in the old tomato game well he thinks
he's a big shot he's gonna give me money
now he's coming for some money he's
gonna make me feel so bad they're
humiliated
screw him
so you get all sorts of behaviors
um
that that are going to express the
variety of human morality
and
so i mean again it's completely
convincing case i think that human being
human behavior can be thought of as
rational in this sense of beliefs and
preferences but the rationality is not
purely self-interested there is this
social rationality aspect so
let's then ask
why is that the case right i mean let's
get into the issue of um how we evolved
these particular sets of uh behaviors
yeah
boy you ask hard questions don't you you
wrote the book
well
you know one thing
that
i should say from the beginning is
i not only believe you have to integrate
the behavioral sciences better that is
so where they overlap they agree
people should know more of of the of the
other sciences so for instance over the
years i've taken it upon myself to learn
all of these disciplines i mean i'm an
old man now i i've learned a lot
including
anthropology so for instance i have
a long article on the evolution of
of um
human socio-political systems
it was a
elite article in current anthropology a
couple of years ago
and so i went through exactly this
question
now it's a very difficult question
but the point is that
it's a long story i think but i think i
worked some of it out the first thing
you have to understand i think is this
the common ancestor of all
the primate species was almost certainly
a multi-male multi-female group
in which
you had
promiscuous relations no pond-bearing
all males
females were accessible to
all females or at least
random parts thereof and male hierarchy
that is run by an alpha male just like
chimpanzees are today
but when humans came along the first the
split between hominids and um
and the other primates
um
the humans
had to cooperate a lot more because they
were doing cooperative hunting
and they developed tools
now what tools the throwing tools they
they had bats and balls and not arrows
that came 20 000 years later or more
much more
and when they became very good at using
these tools
you couldn't support a hierarchy anymore
you couldn't have an alpha male take
over because he's the strongest because
when he goes to sleep you can kill him
i know it sounds silly but think about
it
um chimpanzees can't throw
really or they can but they can't hit
anything when they throw and when they
fight they fight with their hands they
don't fight with any tools of any kind
or
weapons okay
and it takes a very long time for uh
even three chimpanzees to kill a fourth
one
but once you get an accurate weapon
you can kill a guy in his sleep so you
can't maintain
a hierarchy based on power
and human societies move towards
uh cooperative
leadership
it's it's called reverse hierarchy uh by
uh
uh chris baum who were who has worked on
this anthropologically that is
people choose their leaders and they
choose their leaders according to their
ability
to
promote the
values and the fitness of members of the
group
but once you do that then you move
towards having language
because
uh people have to make promises to each
other
um and you have the whole development of
the vocal system of humans which by the
way is not just cognitive it's not just
you got a big brain it's you have
incredible musculature right you have a
larynx which allows you to speak
etc
so the upshot of this is there's a lot
of cooperation
in small-scale hunter-gatherer societies
they're not run hierarchically they're
running
democratically um
and in that situation there's a huge
benefit
to cooperation which
which pays off for the individual
because they're rewarded by other
members of the group
when they behave in a cooperative way
and they're ostracized
when they uh behave in a non-cooperative
way if you want to read about this you
know go to my website and look at some
of the references
but i think that's that's really it
there
human society is very very very
uh
singular compared to i think other
social species in that regard so to
dramatically oversimplify you're saying
that the invention of weapons led to the
invention of language
yeah oh yeah absolutely
is that it can't be
right because the way you defeat
a person who has a good mind and can
speak it
is to have a good mind and speak it yeah
yeah
interesting you can't just bash them
over the head because that doesn't give
you
the the group won't
will elect you their leader
because you bash the leader over the
head and all of your if you have better
ideas
and this is so
this is by the way this goes on right up
to almost the present
the foot soldier people talk about
you know who wins wars
well the answer is foot soldiers win
wars
it's such a shame the united states lost
in vietnam it lost in iraq
right today as we're speaking literally
lost in afghanistan
in all cases
it's
not the item bombs and the big bombers
and the tanks it's the foot soldier okay
so these weapons the democratic weapons
have been a very important source
of uh
uh
basically the democratic success that is
in the in the second world war
and
the cavalry's lost
uh and they lost out to the foot
soldiers with the small caliber weapons
and uh
that gave rise a
strong push for democracy
in um
uh after after the first world war
anyway
yeah i think weapons are very important
well and this is an example especially
because as you mentioned we had to
literally change the biology of our
larynx and our vocal cords and so forth
uh so this is an example of
gene culture co-evolution right i mean
one of the one of the emphasis exactly
you get from your book is
uh some kind of evolutionary psychology
uh plays an important role here right
right
no it's very it but when you really
think about it it's very
dramatic the idea
that i mean
notice first the reason that chimpanzees
can't speak
is not because they're stupid
they can't produce the sounds
chimpanzees go
they can make about six or seven sounds
but they don't have the muscles
in the tongue and in the cheeks
and they don't have the larynx low in
the
throat that allows them to articulate
the way the humans can and that could
only have developed because people who
could communicate that way
were valued and were given more
opportunities to have offspring who had
also those
those characteristics so when people say
language is because people have big
brains that's just not right yeah
people have language because
of gene culture evolution and here's how
it goes
you have a little bit of communication
and people care a lot about it because
they need to communicate to figure out
where to go to find the uh you know
the next
uh
profitable location for hunting and
gathering
and so they reward people who have a
little bit of ability to communicate
that gives rise to genetic changes that
make people
more capable of communicating verbally
and that leads to more cultural
dependency because people use
communication more in their
deliberations and so you have a circle
of genes
affect culture and then the culture
promotes
more genetic behavior yeah
this is only true in humans really
because humans only humans really have
um
cumulative culture
that is where
from one generation to the next
you maintain a body of knowledge and
pass it on
um in animals animals have culture
but they don't have very much uh
cumulative culture if
if birds learn how to open milk bottles
one generation learns how to do it
after a while they forget it goes away
it's not cumulative
yeah from a physics jargon perspective
this uh invention of cumulative culture
was absolutely a phase transition right
in how not only how we behave but how we
evolve for the reasons you just
mentioned i mean very tangible
differences in how our genomes evolve
over time
that's right
exactly
but it does also get us into yet another
hot button issue uh which you have to
talk about which is the group selection
uh controversy as you already mentioned
yeah a while ago there's this sort of um
standard belief
in certain corners of evolutionary
biology of inclusive fitness you know i
would sacrifice
my life for you know two siblings or
four cousins or whatever but the idea
that there are groups that are
attached to each other in evolutionary
ways without necessarily being kin
is a is a controversial one
right
well i've written a lot about this um
and uh
i have a lot of supporters in the
biology community including e.o wilson
and martin novak and other people
and a lot of
there's also it's a very ideological
dispute
and a lot of
population biologists are
pure inclusive fitness
uh supporters and they're wrong i mean
they just it's just wrong
but i'll tell you what's really going on
what's really going on is there's this
guy william hamilton
who was a brilliant biologist and i
loved his work and i love his work
who developed the concept of inclusive
fitness which says
we shouldn't just
be self-interested
we should try to promote our genes
wherever they are right in other people
so we should help
um
we should help
relatives and that's what you said sean
right
problem is this
the model that he built to show this
is a single locus model okay that is you
have a genome
your genome has it has 23 chromosomes
and there are all sorts of genes all
over it
his theory is what happens exactly at
one locus of one chromosome and one
gene at that locus yeah
it's not about all of the loop right
it's about single ones
now the problem is this
what they say in the literature is oh
we'll assume that
it's additive across
genes
that is genes don't affect each other
but they each
follow the same
inclusive fitness rule that is
accused to maximize your your relatives
at that locus
um but the problem is the different loci
have different interests
so i may benefit by helping you at a
different locus
or i may benefit by suppressing you
suppose at locus a you're producing a
poison
that that hurts
it helps you as your gene but it hurts
the rest of the genome yep well the rest
of the genome is going to develop
mutations to suppress that gene
conclusion that's why we have what are
called
mesomorphs that is
multi
multi genetic organisms because the
genes affect each other
they're not they're not they're side by
side they're affecting each other right
and when they affect each other
inclusive fitness
no longer works
now you know
i can say this
you get what i can say is you get a
complex
evolutionary dynamic in the genome
that's well developed in the literature
um you can read oh my people are
interested go to my website
and look up sociobiology and look at the
uh various entries on inclusive fitness
so there is this debate
and um it's actually it's very
interesting it's amusing
um
martin novak and um eo wilson and uh
her co-author carmina
um
published an article in nature i think
or science i forget what nature i think
i'm not sure
um showing that in inclusive fitness
doesn't work
and the response was 127 biologists
sent a letter to nature saying this is
wrong yeah i remember they said you
remember that
i was i was a paul what do you
i said and i'm the first
paragraph
first paragraph of their letter is just
wrong
it's just wrong
so when i see biologists at conferences
i said you signed this why did you sign
this this is just wrong you don't
believe this do you say well you know
oh yeah so we all signed it and it's
crazy
um by the way this reminded me as you
may have seen
you may have seen this
after einstein developed his special
theory there was a book written in
german called um
a hundred authors against einstein and
they asked einstein sir what do you
think of this book a hundred
hundred hotel and
einstein
and he said well if i'm wrong one would
be enough
you ever heard that i have i have but
but i mean just to be fair to the
hundred authors here i mean what was the
argument against the
wilson and novak and tarnita i think
paper
oh i i think that you could
some of the arguments were i think
correct
but
and i don't think their article
was the last word on it i think my
article is the last word
i actually
believe it or not i presented this
article i just
laid out kind of argument for you
i presented it at oxford in the biology
department
which is the uh hotbed of uh inclusive
fitness theory and people were very nice
so uh
it was it's okay uh the whole idea is
this you see
if influence of fitness were true it
would be wonderful because there's no
complexity
there's no evolutionary dynamic needed
it's just one little equation linear
says something like
um
b is greater than rc or br is greater
than c right
right
but it's just not that way you have
social species
that are incredibly complex and diverse
and they can't explain them in terms of
inclusive fitness here now let me say
one final thing on this
group selection
the notion of group selection
when people talk about it it's
they reduce it to groups competing with
each other
group competition even john maynard
smith did this
but that's not right groups
when you say that a certain thing is
selected
it means that it's it doesn't mean it's
selected through competition with others
for instance
if i can escape a fox
that is a fitness enhancement for me i
don't have to fight with another
one of my species i don't have to say
well you know i have to fight with you
you just can't run as fast as i can so i
beat you
similarly group selection in general
means that
the evolutionary dynamic
is favorable
to the
evolution of
of groups with certain social
interactions right
that's all
how it works
inside
is extremely complex and we don't
understand
we don't really understand social
species right we know a little bit about
them but uh there's a lot we don't know
all we can say is
they evolved probably because there was
some
um benefit to this particular social
organization
of that species so for instance
bees are incredibly social
they're not highly related by the way
this is a myth
you know one queen and they're all the
offspring no way first of all queens die
all the time some species of social
species of
bees have six or seven queens
and they can have many
um males
so the genetic there's
this is technical literature but if you
measure the relatedness of
workers and
some species of bees and wasps they're
actually quite low they're almost
to the level of being no relation at all
yeah and they still have incredible
levels of cooperation
so i'm not saying in inclusive fitness
theory is is silly it's very very
important and it explains most of what
happens
but it doesn't explain social species it
explains what happens in basically
non-social species right so we have this
uh development of sociality once we had
weapons and then language
and that sort of has influenced how we
play our games how we think rationally
it becomes social rationality and what
there's obviously a million places to go
here from here but let me hone in on one
thing that you that you say which is
very provocative the idea that uh
we evolve both a private and a public
persona
right i mean and presumably this is
unique to social
species right i mean my my cat doesn't
have a private and public persona it's
more or less the same cat no matter what
is going on so can you say a little bit
more about what these personae are and
uh the the roles they play in our in our
game making life
yeah by a private persona i mean
in daily life
we go around doing our business without
great concerns
for how the whole society works what the
rules of the game are how i relate to
the larger public etc
you know what we're doing now is my
private persona i'm just talking to you
about stuff and you're gonna you know
put it on air and it's not it's gonna go
public i hope you know
excuse me it's gonna go out into the
public i hope you know
yeah yeah that's what's up yeah that's
why i'm talking to you
um okay so
a public persona and in your private
persona you're not asked
to evaluate the impact of everything you
do and everything in the world around
you right
you buy you go to the supermarket you
buy eggs and they're your eggs you're
not concerned about the egg industry or
the farmer's profit or the chickens
usually now that's changed
now you know we only buy free-range
chickens and this and that
but the public persona you automatically
enter a different rain frame in which
you're thinking as a kantian kind of uh
categorical person and you're talking
about what's right and what's wrong who
do i support and who do i not support
what values do i accept in the large and
which do i not
and you get a very different
dynamic for instance one that supports
what i called um
social rationality as opposed to
individual rationality and people do
both all the time yeah so you move from
one to the other now a lot of people
never enter the social realm
they you know i mean i know people they
just never think about anything except
you know what's happening today and
wanting them out for dinner
um and there are few people in the other
they're insufferable
all they think about is that everything
they do
has this deep social meaning
so uh but most people are in the middle
and i haven't i have a typology on that
which i've shown you
there's homosocialism
uh homo universalis homo universalis is
the public persona which is kantian that
is i do what i think is best for the
world as a whole
um
homo um
i forget the names i used even uh
parochialis yes the parochial is i do
best for my group
i vote for my group i support my group
whatever that group is
and that is not a selfish behavior that
by the way
it is a support for a particular social
group
so the public persona isn't just what we
do that is visible to the public but
what we do that is taking the public
into consideration in some sense right
from that from that perspective that
humans have that they can
they can
adjudicate
and
and
uh act
on the rules of the game not just play
within the rules of the game but they
can act on the rules of the game
so uh and and they're very different
hegel had i really got that from hegel
um who talks about exactly that
um
now i should say one more thing that i
think is really interesting
uh it's the term that i coined about the
year 2000 called strong reciprocity what
is strong reciprocity well we have to
start out
this is about humans we have to start
out with what's called reciprocal
altruism
by the great biologist robert trivers
which is some animals and humans
i scratch your back you scratch my back
so we're a mute it's a mutualism but
what i what we found out for humans is
another thing where people
spontaneously help others without
expecting anything in return
and they spontaneously hurt others
without expecting anything positive in
return they simply do it because they
feel like doing it let me give you an
example a few examples this by the way
is really big
um i'm at the airport and i i want to
get to a certain aisle or a certain exit
and i stop someone in the airport and i
say how do i get there and they stop and
they tell me
well why do they do that they don't know
me they're never going to see me again
why would they have someone open the
door for me
if i have a package when i'm going into
a building
that's what i call
the strong reciprocity cooperative that
is
people act like they would like to be
treated themselves right and and and by
the way this is a big deal and so they
don't even care about you
sometimes when i was a kid i used to
drive a truck
uh deliver furniture in philadelphia
this is way before there were gps
systems
so if i had to find the street
i'm looking to stop and look on the map
for five you know for 20 minutes no i
stopped and i asked someone how do i get
to july how do i get to the street half
the time
they always answer and half the time
it's completely wrong
so i hear i was only 17 but i developed
a con i said okay i'm going to invent a
street jalopy street there is no jalopy
street in philadelphia yeah
and i went out and i would fit in my
truck with my furniture in it and i
stopped some guy and say hey where's
jalopy street well you go about three
blocks off into the church you know turn
right
now
that didn't help me at all
but it made him feel real good he's
helping out there you know
so that's the one side the other side is
even more interesting
which is the negative side people love
to hurt people who hurt them
go to your sociology book and see if you
can find the word um retaliation
or um
uh
yeah that
or
vengeance in the index of your sociology
book it's not there
it's treated as a
um
what do you call it it's treated as an
abnormal behavior to one vengeance
and retaliation
but it's one of the basic human
behaviors we do it all the time
people love to hurt people who hurt them
um
i remember
well of course we do a lot of
experiments to show this and this is
really what's going on in the ultimatum
game where a guy rejects a positive
offer
he gets pleasure out of hurting the
other guy who we thought wasn't dealing
with him fairly yeah and this extr
so i tell i used to tell my students
look
there are two kinds of movies
there are love movies and there are
revenge movies
the love movies we all know love is
human and we love
each other the revenge movies the guy
like uh honor schnozeneger gets
his family gets hurt in the beginning
and the rest of the movie goes around
killing everybody in spite i mean you
come out of the movie you say oh that
was really interesting i feel really
good about that movie people love
to reciprocate
uh evil with evil
with no gain in mind
and the thing that's important about
that is that this is a major reason you
have social stability
it's not governments no we didn't humans
didn't have governments
until a few thousand years ago there
were no governments there were no jails
hunter-gatherer societies
they could all they could do is punish
you
or uh ostracize you
and there were no judges
there were no policemen
so strong reciprocity is what kept
things going people helped those that
they thought were being nice and hurt
those who bring not being nice again
this is human behavior
that we discover in the laboratory
that really nobody ever talked about
right
i got the notion because
of an experimentalist who's a
wonderful experimentalist earns fair
uh in zurich
but um so this is what we do we play
games
uh in the laboratory or in the field
um so for instance the ultimatum game
people said about the ultimate okay who
cares about ten dollars
so people it's a little bit of money
okay let's go to a society
a poor society get farmers who make
about 300 a month
and play the ultimatum game
for hundred dollars or a thousand
dollars there you'll see whether they
accepted
you know what happens
it's nothing different they still reject
three they'll reject a month's wages
wow well i i mean this is clear that
you've already made this connection but
let's just draw it out because it's so
important because what you're getting at
is the idea that these
kinds of socially motivated behaviors
even taken and abstracted outside of an
explicitly social context uh can be
derived or thought of starting from
these principles of some kind of
rationality played out by a game theory
right i think that probably a lot of
people have this idea that once you
start talking about rational actors and
game theory you're going to end up with
selfishness and individuality and and
but you're getting from there to social
behavior in a very uh connected
entangled kind of way
whoa absolutely that's that's
you know the beginning when when darwin
did his stuff
people said oh it's
it's uh nature tooth and clad and tooth
and claw you know it's all about
competition
but for the past hundred years almost
it's been about cooperation that's what
really
works well and sam balls and i one my
co-op is we wrote a book called the
cooperative species
a cooperative species and explaining how
human cooperation evolved now part of
that is
cooperation evolves because
hunter-gatherer groups make war against
each other and to make war you have to
cooperate
non-social species do not make war
right only social species can make war
like you know ants or humans
so um yeah we're all about how evolution
develops not only
uh
conflict and um
a struggle it also
explains cooperation
well maybe this is a good
place to give you the final question
final issue anyway to talk about i
always say it's the final question but
then follow-up sometimes happens so the
final thing to talk about i'll give you
a softball i'll give you an easy
question um
you've mentioned how these different
disciplinary approaches end up talking
about human beings in very different
ways and they should talk to each other
more etc so
how do we fix that
how do we fix academia and our
intellectual lives so that these ideas
are not siloed so strongly that we don't
even talk to each other anymore well the
the first thing to note there are two
really important developments to notice
one is um
if you look at
scientific results in the behavioral
sciences
they have been interdisciplinary as
people who have have approached things
for instance in epidemiology
it's not just
it's not just microbiology
it's also social interaction so the
whole theory of
of
um uh
of uh viruses and their spread epidemics
etc
involves
both sociology
and microbiology
so the the gain from doing these things
in a more
uh
transdisciplinary way is very high
now for me the second thing has been the
internet
when i was younger i i still thought the
same way but i'd have to go to the
library at harvard
uh widener library and i was very strong
i take out journals
and bring them home
piles of journals
but it still took weeks sure to do
anything
now with the internet i can learn a new
subject in you know
a year
without any problem now i must say i'm
now
working on physics and physics is harder
than
some of the other subjects uh it's
taking me five years so far
but um i think the internet has made all
the difference in the world
uh in in the ability to gather
information from all over and to talk to
experts in fields that are not your own
and places far away from you so i think
it's happening and there are
there are examples of it um for instance
the university of uh arizona
is organized
in an interdisciplinary way and i think
it's been very successful
now what else can i say about that um
i think that's that's about it i will
say that for young people when you start
out you have to
go into a particular
discipline and you have to really learn
very well
before you
can branch out
but i had the idea a long time ago
of setting up a school where the first
year behave for behavioral students
people studying
you know life behavior of life forms
that the first year you all learn the
same thing you learn statistics you
learn mathematical model building you
learn the scientific method
and then
you learn the basic core of every one of
the fields psychology sociology
political theory economics
anthropology
and then in your third year you start um
specializing on what you want to do
but uh and i think that's not a bad
model
um
so
that's all i can say
now i should say this there's also a
political problem
for instance i have found
very high levels of
political ideology
tainting
people's
judgment in almost all of these fields
for instance sociologists tend to be
extremely liberal as far as i know
i joined the asa for a few years and it
felt like i was back in sds
um
in 1960
1968 or something like that
um
support the workers at the school such
and such and this and that
um
and anthropologists
have gone into um what's called
um post-modernism yeah which is a denial
of the importance of science me you
probably had
had experience with that
and
i've done a lot of work in anthropology
with my co-authors
it's very hard to get anthropologists to
think scientifically
and uh the it was very hard for us to
get funded by the nsf
because they they run their um
they run their uh proposals through a
council of
anthropologists sure and anthropologists
don't like to go in there and experiment
on the uh
you know on the simple society people
um when we try to public i've published
a lot with princeton university press i
think it's a very good press
but when we submitted our anthropology
book to them which is called uh
small-scale societies
um the anthropologists wouldn't touch it
so it got published by oxford so there's
political political stuff all over the
place
um and
um it will take a long time
but but it's very i think it's very
interesting
that uh you know scientists
talk about being
interested in getting the truth but when
they disagree with each other if they're
not in the same field
who cares
forget about it i think that's a very
strange attitude
well and and your mention of the funding
situation is also important right i
think a lot of people give lip service
to being interdisciplinary but they only
have finite resources and when they
partial them out they're going to
partial them out to the people who do
things that they feel comfortable with
right
no i'm sure but they why don't they feel
comfortable with our
doing game theory in 15 small-scale
societies well one person did
yeah a senior you know nsf guy and he
pushed through the funding that we
needed
to to actually carry out these
experiments it was not a lot it was a
few million dollars
and uh
and uh but it's still very difficult
interdisciplinary is very difficult and
people think interdisciplinary means
while you just combine the wisdom of the
different disciplines but that's false
because the wisdoms don't agree with
each other right they don't add up they
are contradictory
so you have to work i've done that in
two books one book
um
game theory evolving i said what does
economics have to change in order to be
compatible with sociology and political
theory and psychology
in my last book which is called
individuality and entanglement
i asked mostly the other question that
is what do the other disciplines have to
do to be compatible with economics but i
think there's a lot more work to be done
in these areas
well that's always a good place to end
there's a lot more work to be done i'm
hoping that a lot of young people are
listening here and being inspired and
you've given good advice that it's good
to
learn a discipline and master it before
moving on to learn many more but uh oh
yeah you'll never
not only because
you need to get a job but also you have
to you have to get really deep into a
subject right
to know what's going on
if you've never done that you know if
you're taking the phil the philosopher's
road
you're not going to be able to deal with
the intricacies of particular
disciplines
you need this it's flesh of working out
one particular one i'm tempted to defend
the philosophers here because they get
into the nitty-gritty of their own
individual issues more than any other
field that i know well i know i i i need
a lot of philosophy of physics and i
think a lot of people are very very good
at it
but i must say i rather spend my time
learning a standard model fair enough i
cannot reading more philosophy cannot
argue with that okay so herb guintas
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast this is a very
eye-opening thought-provoking
conversation okay it was been fun thanks
john
[Music]
you